a new caravan of some 1800 Central
Americans is making its way towards the
u.s. this morning they started crossing
in New Mexico from Guatemala late last
week and continued arriving through the
weekend Adriana Diaz is in Co dad
Hidalgo Mexico on the Mexican side of
the bridge where migrants enter from
Guatemala
Adriana good morning good morning the
migrants are camped out here as far as
you can see on this bridge that side of
the bridge is Guatemala we are on the
Mexican side there waiting to be
officially registered by the Mexican
government in a new process that just
started a week ago in preparation for
this Caravan what happens is is when
people arrive they receive wristbands to
register them their identity is verified
and then five days later they can
receive humanitarian visas allowing them
to stay in Mexico for a year to work and
to live now this is a stark contrast to
the last major caravan that passed
through in October that Caravan at its
height had more than 7,000 people and
clashed with police on this very same
bridge the bridge was so packed that
people actually chose to jump off the
bridge to try to swim to Mexico as for
where that caravan stands roughly 2600
people made it to the border tried to
cross illegally and were arrested by
u.s. Border Patrol about 1300 didn't get
that far they chose to go back to their
home countries essentially giving up
nearly 3,000 people received Mexican
visas and fewer than 700 people remain
at Tijuana trying to seek asylum we've
spoken to people here this morning who
told us they found out about this latest
caravan on Facebook they're trying to
head north to the US border one father
actually told us that he saw I was
American and he said will they let us in
with our children Nora
alright Adriana thank you